hello everyone
welcome to pi data boss's november
meetup for those of you who don't know
high data is an educational program of a
non-profit organization called num focus
the global pi data network promotes
discussion of best practices
new approaches and emerging technologies
for data management
processing analytics and visualization
we are a community of users and
developers of open source data analysis
tools and this meetup is a forum for us
to share ideas
and learn from each other we also
approach data science using many
languages
including but not limited to python
julia
and r my name is anita yeth and i worked
with fellow
pi data co organizer uh tyler miguel
to bring you to tonight's talk we're
thrilled to have two presentations for
you tonight
first austin aovito will deliver a talk
on explainable workflows using python
focusing on skills and tactics used to
help
data scientists articulate their
findings to end users
stakeholders and other data scientists
then
we'll hear from angela vujick on brain
computer interfaces
where she'll be presenting a tutorial on
how to interface with the open bci
using python and useful python libraries
for electrophysiology
now before we get to them i want to
touch base on a few items
first feel free to introduce yourself in
the chat and in slack where
there's also an introductions channel as
we continue to hold these
virtual events we want to continue
building our community and of course
if you have questions during the
presentation please unmute yourself and
chime in
for real-time conversations for those of
you who aren't speaking please make sure
to turn off your microphones
you can find us at our website
boston.pidata.org
and on social media feel free to tweet
about today's event
using pi data boss
if you haven't joined our slack
community yet please do so
this information is also in our meetup
page
second we have our annual member survey
that we sent out earlier this week
in slack and via email we'll drop it in
the chat as well
and just let us know how we're doing
what kind of programming you want to see
what topics you want to discuss in the
coming year and whether you might be
interested in helping us
organize events whatever feedback you
have we want to hear from you
third pi data boston's next event will
be held on thursday december 17th
where we'll talk about all things
machine learning the evening we'll start
off with stanley jung providing
a comprehensive guide on the
applications of pseudo-labeling and how
he won a kaggle medal using only
pseudo-labeling
afterwards
will deliver a talk on topic modeling
for data discovery and focus in on a
cyber security use case anyone from
machine learning enthusiasts to experts
will take away some new knowledge from
this event
so we hope you'll be able to join us
then
as of all meetings we want to reiterate
that pi data is dedicated to
providing a harassment free event
experience for everyone
please behave professionally as we do
not tolerate harassment in any form
you can view the longer version of our
code of conduct at this website
so feel free to reach out to any one of
the organizers if you have concerns
thank you for helping to make this a
welcome community for all
of course these meetings are only made
possible with the help of volunteers
you can do anything from organizing an
event by recruiting speakers to creating
partnerships
let us know if you're interested by
filling out the annual member survey
what's more we have an ongoing need for
speakers
so please consider volunteering to
present and speak at one of our meetings
you don't have to have a full talk ready
when you fill out our speaker form on
our website
as the organizing team will help you
through that
lastly before we kick it off we want to
give it a quick shout out to one of our
sponsors ibm
so at this time i'll pass it over to tim
bonaman to give a quick intro
on something ibm has been working on
yeah hi there uh my name is tim boniman
i
am with uh the speaker tonight austin uh
on
the um ibm data science community team
uh we are a place for
now over 14 000 um professionals um who
are working on
am i ai machine learning all other data
science topics to you know share learn
um and uh
get better at what they're doing um and
uh if you choose to join right now we
have a little offer a little goodie
there
you get one month complimentary access
to select ibm courses on coursera um
they're they're pretty good they cover a
wide variety of
topics and um
experience levels so give it a look
um and with that i uh
turn it back and enjoy the event tonight
thanks tim i'm gonna turn it over to
tyler to now introduce our next speaker
i think you want to one sec just switch
the slide back
perfect hi everyone i'm tyler miguel and
i'm here
co-hosting with anita and i'm excited
for
the talk that we have for you right now
uh about explainable workflows in python
i am definitely a huge fan of this so
i'm looking forward to hearing what
austin has to say i'll just make a quick
intro
so austin's data scientist on the
technical marketing team
uh technical marketing and evangelism
team at ibm in san francisco california
so it's definitely great that we have
this that he can check in all the way
here in boston
as a recent graduate student of florida
state university austin's focused on the
balance of bleeding edge research
produced by
academia and tools using applied data
science his master thesis was on
white collar crime using time aware
joint topic sentiment analysis
and his areas of interest are nlp
applied data science and explainable ai
perfect talk for tonight uh outside of
his work he enjoys spending time with
his dog and traveling
so without further ado i will close my
mouth
and allow austin to take you from here
awesome thanks so much for the great
introduction tyler and anita and um
thank you to the pi data community at
large for having me uh
really happy to give this talk so with
that being said is it okay if i just
dive right into it tyler
absolutely you should be able to uh take
over in screen share as well
all right awesome
uh right now it says host disabled
attendee screen sharing so maybe
just need to wait
yep we'll change that right now awesome
um so i guess while we wait on that
maybe some uh if you would like you can
drop in the chat i feel like you're
familiar with uh the idea of
explainability
um specifically an ai uh
and if you are familiar with it if you
have it like have you used it in your
work
um so maybe you can just throw that in
the chat all right good to go
all right cool so y'all can see my
screen um
all right and uh before we dive into it
i do want to say if you have any
questions at any time feel
free to uh you know take yourself on you
and
ask and then uh what just happened um
and as long as we have as long as time
permits we'll get to it and i'll answer
to the best of my ability and if i can't
answer it then i will direct you to a
resource that can't answer it
um so yeah so why are you guys here
today we're going to be talking about
explainability and how that fits in data
science routines specifically what does
it look like as a workflow
um so what this is going to be is it's
going to be like 10 15 minutes of
powerpoint and then we will go through
a jupiter notebook that is on github so
if you want to go and clone that and
play around with it
uh post talk you can do that
so i like to start with this slide
because i think it kind of sets the mood
um
there are three kinds of lies lies
damned lies and statistics
uh no one knows who that's attributed to
but it was popularized by mark twain
um we have the george box quote that i'm
sure everyone knows all models are wrong
some are useful
um and then the last one is just why do
you do that that's something i'm sure
everyone's heard in their
everyday life from uh you know work to
coming home
to doing chores uh we are often asked to
explain our reasoning or
why we did something um and we're gonna
apply that to the data science routines
that are popularized in business right
now
so you're here so that by the end of
this talk you'll have an idea of what
this graphic
or what this graphic is uh what
information it's relaying but more
importantly how can you apply this in
your day-to-day work
and how can you use this to relay your
findings uh your experience
and the work you're actually doing to
stakeholders in a way that's conducive
to meeting business priorities
um so this is probably the most text
we're gonna see on one of the slides um
so i'm not going to read all
uh all of it i will give you time to
read over it but the high
level topics i'd like to take away from
this is that using explainable workflows
will give you more time to develop the
understanding of why
you're doing things uh not not just
necessarily how and
why we're doing this to meet business
criterion um and it will also augment
your ability to deduce where things are
going awry so
you know internally as a data scientist
giving you a better more comprehensive
overview
of what you're performing um and allow
you to debug it
hopefully we don't have bugs in our code
but you know that's just nature of the
job
and then resolve this with other data
scientists and more importantly
stakeholders and if you know regulated
industry
regulators and things of that nature um
so i'll probably give you guys a few
more seconds
to finish reading this
um so i do think it's important to
operationalize terms that we're using
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to talk about what does word
interpret mean
um this is just the miriam webster
dictionary definition so
to explain or tell the meaning of
present in understandable terms
but the way we operationalize this and
explainable workflows um
an explainability at large is the idea
that this is a static development
um we may be running something from
logistic regression to a neural network
and everything in between
and we may get some arbitrary uh
you know criterion out so you know
whatever our objective function is
whether that's accuracy
auc roc things of that nature um and
we're able to evaluate that and that
conforms to
you know our experience what we expect
the behaviors to be of this model and
things of that nature
um so interpret once again it's static
we do it at the time
of you know revelation so when our
process is finished running we can look
at it and see
you know do we agree with these results
um i do think uh at this point it's
really important to
bring into the idea of being skeptical
um
on your first pass of new data post you
know exploratory data analysis
um you should be somewhat skeptical so
that's not just
low results like returning 30 accuracy
should also be you know if this is your
first go round you get 96
accuracy uh that's something you should
delve into more because more often than
not something
you know we may be overfitting something
be going awry a multitude of issues but
once again
we're doing this statically
versus the idea of explanation this is
once again the merriam-webster
dictionary uh definition
which is to make known uh we define
explainability in this context however
as like a dynamic process so
uh we get some kind of accuracy metric
we interpret it we're either satisfied
dissatisfied maybe we're neutral
um we ideate we innovate and then we
you know rerun the model uh you know
once we made some changes
we have a new metric that we can
interpret and by dynamically doing this
you know cyclically using version
control things of that nature
the idea is to deduce understanding of
both our model and how it's meeting the
business criterion so you know
insularly as an individual and as a team
we can you know mitigate against future
bugs and you know build a
holistic understanding of how our work
is impacting the business
um as well as you know take it to
stakeholders regulators give talks on
and things of that nature
um so uh just to reiterate these two
concepts
interpret is static explaining is a
dynamic process and it's ongoing
uh normally post deployment as well with
things of data drift and
things beyond this talk
uh so what does this really mean these
are two quotes take from uh taken from
dennis hinton
um who writes about causation and causal
inference uh
the verb to explain is a three-placed
predicate someone explains something to
someone
um in this case a data scientist
explains something about their code
or the results of their code to someone
or maybe it may not be their code it may
be
coding practices things of that nature
um and in its wider sense attribution
describes a process
whereby one ascribes some phenomenon to
its origin um meaning
you know uh if a dog barks in the bay
and you know you have a baby and your
baby wakes up you would attribute the
dog barking to your baby waking up
even though there's you know a wide
gambit of reasons why the
the child may have awakened um so once
again these are from dennis hinton
and then at this place i will tell you i
don't think it's my bibliography
but um if you want to get more into
causation and you know like the
the logical side logical mathematics
side of
causal inference and statistics and
machine learning i do
recommend reading uh judea pearls papers
on um
causal inference uh i don't think
they're my bibliography but they're on
arcsiv
so if anyone wants those i can drop
those in the chat
um but that's kind of the the extension
of where this slide's going
um so to wrap up the previous uh slides
we define explainability as the ability
for data scientists
results to be understood and interpreted
by other data scientists and
stakeholders
um as well as themselves so it you know
there's kind of two modalities
internally can you vet and debug a model
and you know comprehensively understand
what you're doing beyond just
implementing it and then secondly um can
you
uh explain this to another person um i
can't remember who popularized the quote
it might have been fineman or something
like that but like if you can't explain
something
uh to a five-year-old you probably don't
understand it uh that might be
a little bit too much uh too hyperbolic
in this sense but you know
the uh the gist behind it you know we
can kind of relate to that in the
guise of explainability um so this
graphic is just uh
letting us know that you know there are
disparate stakeholders that are going to
vary on their experience
their need and their technical uh skill
so
you know we relay that with this
three-dimensional graph so experiences
on the x-axis
technical skills on the y-axis and needs
on the z-axis
um so as you can see a regulator may be
someone who's relatively experienced
relatively technically skilled but has a
high need uh we have
end users data scientists and management
so
once again um it's a dynamic process
this idea of explaining and it's also
going to have to cater to your end users
to their persona
um so what you wouldn't do is if you're
presenting how your neural network is
going to reduce customer churn you would
not go
and meet with business stakeholders and
tell them uh
you know how you did batch normalization
and all these crazy technical details
that may
not be pertinent to them and vice versa
if you're doing a code review
you may not be telling them um you know
how this is going to save
20 uh you know costs over time
uh you know we want to give people the
relevant information
that is going to be most impactful to
them and empower them to do their job
and perform better
uh for the sake of themselves and the
overall business so once again
this idea is to not replicate or create
redundant work for data scientists
it's simply an augmentation to perhaps
you know mitigate some of the headaches
that happens when um you know we're
doing technical work and we need to find
a way to one
reconcile that internally but also you
know relay information
to other people who may not have the
same experiences as us
uh so here's just a quick research
overview um that these are kind of like
the papers i think
you should definitely read if you're
going to kind of venture into this
uh side of machine learning and deep
learning things that nature so
the first one's by cynthia rudin it's
stop explaining black box machine
learning models for high stakes
decisions and use
interpretable models instead uh it's
really good because it's just going to
give you a well
um rounded point of view so she's not
necessarily for
post or ad hoc explanations for ideas we
could use directly interpret models
from the get-go so things like decision
trees
um you know rule-based models and her
uh major you know facts behind that is a
thing called
like the compass uh program that
happened in florida
was basically disproportionately um
affecting
uh people based off of their skin color
and what and it was a black box model
that no one could reconcile with
so what they did instead is they brought
in bucks a bunch of experts and created
a rule-based system
that actually allowed them to one uh
affect people equally
um and secondly it was explainable and
people were able to you know debug and
look through it uh in case there were
counter factuals the second one is from
darpa
explained by artificial intelligence
they kind of lay out the groundwork of
what they're going to do with this
program
uh what schools are getting funding and
where those uh what directions they're
headed in
so that's a pretty cool so you can keep
up with that research
why should i trust you explain the
predictions of any classifier
that's the line paper which is um
lime and chap are kind of you know the
entry way into explainability they're
pretty uh generalizable and uh good
helpful debugging tools then we have
type driven automated learning with
wallet towards robust interpretability
with self-explained neural networks
um and then ted teaching ai to explains
decisions
um so once again these are in the
bibliography but if anyone wants to be
specifically pointed to things beyond
this
just ask uh this is where the demos live
on github so get hot
github.com ibm aix360
and lawless lawless the library we'll be
using
for uh rapid prototyping and aix 360 is
what we will be using for explainability
and then uh there's a master class as
well uh ibm
explainability.bmap.com
uh that's just a a picture um and then
here's the bibliography before we go and
look at some code
so uh i will end that and pull up the
code does anyone have any questions
it does not look like anyone has any
questions
all right cool and it looks like we have
some extra time um so here let me make
this full screen
so this is just a graphic from the aix
360 library that i want to show everyone
um before we begin that kind of outlines
some of the uh different algorithms
available to you uh where they can be
used and what they do for uh what
they'll do for you
or how they'll augment your work uh how
should better say that
um so you know do we want to understand
our data or a model there's a split
we have this suite of algorithms proto
dash and dipvay um
and then if we want to understand our uh
model we have
um you know another split local versus
global uh interpretations
um so this is just a breakdown this is
at the aix 360 github in case anyone
wants to look at it in
more detail and there is a academic
paper associated with all of these
with that being said we will dive on in
um so i'm gonna skip around and
hopefully i don't
mess up anyone's uh anyone's eyes
uh is this large enough for everyone to
see
all right no one said no so i will
assume that we are good to go
um we have some yeses in the chat you're
looking good awesome
all right awesome um so yeah so this is
just a really brief description of the
bank data uh
the data set so this is the bank and
marking data set
uh portuguese banking and marketing data
set from uci
uh the link's right here in case anyone
wants to try it once again this is on
github so
you can clone it fork it what have you
uh
this is just a breakdown of you know the
data
uh you know with you know indicating if
it's categorical
if it's uh an object things that nature
uh numerical um so we're not going to
really go into that
uh i'm going to kind of
probably should have done more research
i'm going to make the assumption
everyone's fairly
um fairly uh familiar with kind of like
the pandas and visualizations and things
of that nature
so i'm going to kind of breeze through
that part to get to more informative
parts for
you guys the end user um that being said
i am going to drop duration right here
it's important to note because the goal
behind this
is for us to identify whether or not
users are going to open a term with a
bank
and secondly identify the principal
features that contribute
to them uh opening or not opening a bank
account
um so if this is going to you know
classify users
uh in real time you know to make it
realistic we're not going to have the
duration of the call
as the call's occurring you know we may
have other information such as their age
their job
if they're married but you don't know uh
how long the call is going to be until
it ends and then the other thing is
for modeling duration ends up being
you know i guess i'll spoil for you
basically the principal
contributing factor where like you could
remove all the other features
and duration is going to give you almost
70 percent accuracy
um just because it you know uh there
it's a linear separable um meaning you
know if
the call is less than five minutes
that's normally enough for you know very
brief greeting very brief exit and
nothing really happens versus
a 30 minute uh long call something
probably happened there
so we're really you know it's really
easy to determine based off that so we
drop
it um you know we just do
uh we do describe so we can describe our
numerical features
um you know this gives us a kind of an
understanding of
okay so this is average age you know
different things of that nature um these
last uh are not number employed but
four of these are government mandated
like um
think of them like interest rates things
of that nature so once again um
the data set link is at the top of this
notebook so you can look into it more
um but for this i just kind of want to
show off the tooling and the thought
process behind the workflow rather than
just
you know really dive into the data um
you know we we cast dataframe.info to
make sure you know what are our types
are there any nulls things that nature
this is just really standard stuff to
make sure that we are moving forward
um you know making proper assumptions
we don't want to make unreasoned
assumptions uh we visualize
real quick you know just to get an idea
of the data this is
what i do in my work i you know do some
kind of exploratory data analysis
um you know even if the data is clean
it's worth looking into
inspecting um you know because
ultimately as data scientists before we
model or do any of the
fancy cool stuff that people want to see
talks about um you know we need to clean
curate or purge data
um because ultimately you know garbage
and garbage out
so you know we see that the age
distribution is skewed um so that's
interesting to us
uh you know that can inform our future
decisions or our future
uh interpretations of results because
you know we have statistically
significant information
may not be the job of a data scientist
at this point but based off of trends or
patterns that we see emerging
a statistician or someone could come in
uh or yourself could do hypothesis
testing
um and that would normally be introduced
post visualization but for once again
the sake of this talk we're going to
kind of just get to the
part where we explain
um so it's just visualizations uh
once again um you know statically we
interpret
and then dynamically we explained so
interpreting this
uh you know made it just oh it's just a
pie chart
you know pie charts aren't super fancy
and then uh histogram
but you know beyond this as a you know
if we're working in a business
environment what does it actually tell
us
uh we have a very underrepresented
minority
um classness you know one out of ten of
them
one out of ten observations is open to
term so
you know we see we have an unbalanced uh
data set so that informs us that
hey maybe we need to do majority over
sampling or minority
or majority under sampling minority
oversampling things of that nature
maybe we use smo there's a variety of
techniques that we could use to try and
balance this data set
um more importantly as a part of
explaining uh this is maybe where we
would
you know if people aren't aware of this
we make our team aware you know maybe
talk to our
inline manager say hey um is something
we need to mitigate against or fix
maybe it's left up to you that's really
you know insular to your business
apparatus and how you guys perform your
work
uh the important thing is though this is
something that's worthy of note
um and uh if it is something that's
determined to be reconciled that we
uh you know it's important that we have
the tooling to reconcile but it's also
we
we understand that it's there uh what we
wouldn't want to do is just move past
this and assume you know there's a 50 50
split
um things of that nature so that's just
kind of me
backing up why i think visualization is
important beyond just it's uh
interesting and novel way to show off
data
uh you know and so this also breaks down
uh whether or not people opened or
didn't open based off their uh
education what i'm looking for here is
just are there any tr
uh any trends where perhaps you know
people with a post-grad education
are you know a majority class things of
that nature
just just in case
we have a couple of questions uh in the
chat austin and one of the
questions from monica is how much slower
is xml compared to conventional
approaches
xml uh oh like explainable machine
learning
um i don't think it's actually that much
slower and i'll show you why
um it might be it it might be slow like
the first two times but i'm a big fan of
i use jupiter notebook for prototyping
but python files for
you know production things um that being
said what i think's really
important is like if you have scripts
you're going to use quite a lot you can
save them
and you know use arcs or quarks and
you know you can feed them arbitrary
parameters and you'll be able to reuse
it
most of the time um and you only have to
fine tune it every once in a while
so it's really just getting the pattern
down uh just like with all things coding
uh yes that is the um github link and
then what parts of xml xa i do most
novices get stuck in with analysis and
design
um so i'll go back to the code
uh sorry uh so where do novices get
stuck
honestly um
from my experience uh and you know i
i recently got a job at ibm i've been
here for around a year but uh the
biggest
the biggest differentiator from when i
was in academia um
versus now uh beyond explainability but
i'll get back to explainability because
it all ties together is um
problem identification normally in
academia or on
um kaggle or a lot of things the
problem's going to be presented to you
in a way where you're solving for
something and there's like
decision boundaries um you're told you
know
what you're going to predict here's the
inputs things of that nature um
and it's it's well-bounded you know what
decisions you can make that are going to
eventually lead you to success and then
in that sense prototyping becomes much
easier uh where i see a lot of um
i don't want i would be apprehensive say
novices but maybe just for people who
have not uh
been able to gain the experience or
haven't been introduced to certain kinds
of problems
get stuck is problem segmentation and
understanding that um you may not just
be able to accomplish a task with one
model
you know convolutional neural net
network may not be the solution
even though we're dealing with images um
and more importantly
where i see people get stuck is spending
a sprint or two working on that solution
and finding out it wasn't the right
solution
and having to drop it um so a term i
heard recently is uh
you know have strong opinions that are
loosely held i think that's a really
uh key part of explainability because
what you want to do
one one um the biggest benefactor of
explainability is ultimately going to be
you because it gives you the ability
to not only debug but prove yourself
wrong and prove your assumptions wrong
before you get to the code review or
pushing it to
a unit test uh because that would be
you know that's going to eat into
management's time your time everyone's
time versus you being able to reconcile
things internally by using the suite of
tools so i say that's the biggest
differentiator is
understanding problems and how uh
as data scientists the programs and
methods we use are tools
rather than you know just the solution
um so i say that's the biggest
differentiator so i forgotten going on a
little bit of a tangent but that was a
good question
um so we're still looking at
visualizations
um you know just a breakdown so contact
method
uh telephone versus cellular um i don't
remember exactly when the status that's
from but it's
obviou not really recent because most
people don't have a home telephone
anymore well
um i'm sorry that's not fair assumption
i i don't live in portugal so perhaps
it's different
but um you know so once again these are
things we could look at and you know
we seem to have much better margins when
we reach out on cellular so there's
recommendations things you can do
um as that scientist i always have a
notebook next to me
or notes open on my computer second
monitor and i'm constantly uh
writing these things that i'm saying
down um so okay so now we're into the
we're into the cool stuff um so with
that being said
all right i'm gonna start going faster
because i don't uh want to leave anyone
hanging
um so we're gonna do some prep for
modeling this is just really standard
stuff we split into train test split
for x and y uh that we get from our data
frame
we split it into numerical and
categorical columns
um we encode uh we encode our x values
uh with ordinal encoder the reason we do
this um
even though we split them and so that
way we can do a cool visualization
so you know once again the tools we're
using aren't necessarily the solution
they're a way for us to arrive at the
solution so i decided to use ordinal
encoder encode all my data into integers
and then um you know once they're
numeric and they're ordinally scaled i
can do a correlation map
so uh i just figured out you know
uh i think you know certain certain
features are going to be highly
correlated with one another uh so you
know like multicollinearity
and i should remove it based off of that
um i didn't end up removing any just
because
in case anyone uses this they can see
how it's going to affect
their outcomes um so yeah but
obviously you can see based off the
color mapping
there are certain things that we should
probably remove but we didn't
just so that way we have more
information to see things for our first
run
um so we're gonna do a rule-based
algorithm this is from aix 360. this is
uh
rule-based methods um what's important
to note is that we binarize our features
what that really means is like
um rather than so if it's categorical
value uh we take the
cat number of categories and multiply by
two because it's now binarized so
if we have um education which could be
high school
four-year degree uh masters right now
that becomes
three separate columns where each column
is a boolean value
uh for each observation what that does
is that basically it's like an arbitrary
way of expanding the amount of
information captured by our data
so we can come up with more
comprehensive rules this is covered
in the academic paper there's a lot of
underlying things going on
but ultimately what this is going to
return to us is you know our arbitrary
objective function
and rules governing how we got that
function
um or how we got that result so
uh you know it runs and what we see is
that the previous outcome so this
if you dive into it this variable this
variable indicates
has this person been contacted before
and if they have been contacted before
was it successful or not successful um
and so what we determine is that we get
a training and test accuracy of almost
90 percent
based off of one rule uh where we will
predict
uh they didn't open a term if any of the
are they open a term if any of the
following rules are satisfied
otherwise it wasn't so if uh
outcomes not equal to success then we uh
we deduce that they did not open a term
if their previous outcome was successful
then we determined that they will
open an account um and as you can see
i'm just going to scroll up one
uh one more time um i'm not going to go
too much into the background of how this
is working per se um
you know i don't want to say that's not
important it's extremely important
but what i do think is to show back to
one of the questions before is how much
time would this take
as you can see this is a pretty standard
like sk learnesque uh you know
instantiate your model uh fit
score and you know that's what we do
and it works pretty well so now what we
do is we're going to rapidly prototype
to see you know
um what other algorithms can compete in
this space
so we have an arbitrary baseline of
around 89 using one rule
um so that you know that indicates to us
that
we're probably shooting for something
around that um using some other methods
and if not we should you know try and
deduce y
uh depending on our time constraints so
we just import a bunch of things from
sklearn um we use la le
uh it's important to note wally does rap
sk learn so
a lot of the underlying dependencies are
the same and a lot of the underlying
uses
are very similar that being said there's
just a little bit um
there are some my new differences with
how all uh with how lala handles things
as well as the operators are a little
bit
um prettier in my taste uh for
pipelining and things of that nature
um and what it is is you know it's a
semi-automated data science library so
what it's going to do it's going to help
you with uh
algorithm selection hyper parameter
optimization um
things of that nature so these are all
the different scores
we could use uh for our methods
um and then this is where we instantiate
our pipeline so this is a trainable
pipeline where we use call and
transformer
all that's gonna do is segment our data
based off of its numerical or
categorical
and then based off of that it's either
going to use the l1 normalize it
normalize it using the l1 norm and then
if it's categorical we'll do one hot
encoding
excuse me and then we feed it into a
logistic regression
we fit it it's gonna find some arbitrary
hyper uh
hyper parameters for us and then we test
it
so our uh roc auc score is not good
um our accuracy scores similar to what
we got with the rule based algorithm
um and then what we can also do is we
can write out to json our hyper
parameters
so you could pickle this you can also
pickle the trained or untrained model so
that way you can share with data
scientists for debugging
um things that nature uh so yeah this is
just like the
a json file of what we actually just did
with that pipeline
and it will point to the documentation
um this is the same thing just pretty
printing it
um so now we are going to try it again
this is rapid prototyping so logistic
regression gave us very similar results
um now we're going to see well logistic
regression let's see how that compares
with xg boost and decision trees
um so it's the same thing uh now
all we've done change has given
numerical uh columns the ability to be
normalized
or have no operation done to it based
off of how it affects the
um and the metric
uh we use hyperopt uh hyperopt is
different than like grid search or smack
or things of that nature because you
don't need to
pre-identify search space um we just
tell it what estimator we want which is
the pipeline that we planned out the
number of evaluations in our scoring
we fit it uh we get a summary of our
five pipelines
we can figure out which one's our best
and our worst
and we get our accuracy and our roc ac
so so far we haven't beaten
our initial rule based uh algorithm
cross validate um lawley does do cross
validation under the hood
this is just to make sure that you know
uh proof of concept
make sure everyone's on the same page
it's always good to uh
it's always good to you know test your
your underlying
like method abstractions every once in a
while because um
yeah i think as a data scientist you
take for granted uh how much of
how much of this stuff is pre-written
for us um so it's always good to just
double check make sure that everything's
performing the way you think it is even
though you've read the documentation
um so that's what i did here and then i
get an accuracy
and the standard uh deviation um and
then i print out our final
estimator so we did no operation on the
numericals we did one hot
coding and our best and algorithm was a
tree
uh and it will return our hyper
parameters that we used
uh right here so
um so to someone's question if this
takes a lot more time
uh not really because you can use rapid
prototyping to identify your candidate
models and based off your candidate
models that's when you start getting
your hands dirty
with fine-tuning um you know things of
like
do you need really high metrics or do
you need fast inference
um what are the trade-offs and you
so the idea that we should be coming
away with this is like this is once
again an iterative process but secondly
like
we're informing ourselves by asking
questions of
you know our results so that way when we
go to others where we're not only ready
to answer their questions
uh if we have questions of our own we
can ask them to help them resolve you
know like hey
i realize certain ones my models get
very similar accuracy
uh but some of them run much more
quickly
you know which one should i prioritize
um so
you know as you can see there's a lot of
things going on here um
this is just some of the tooling you can
use to uh help you out with it
um okay so i'm gonna speed up real quick
this is just more of me
showing uh lawley um
so ultimately once we have that pipeline
what you can do
is you can pass it into lime from aix360
you can pass the whole pipeline and it's
going to
re-perform the computations with minor
perturbations to the
um data that you input and what these
perturbations are going to do is allow
you to get like what the future
relevance is
um kind of glazing over it but these are
local interpret
interpretations because they're local
perturbations um
so this is not like glo to all of your
data this is for
a specific observation um so for this
specific observation of
index 500 we uh see the predicted class
is zero they didn't open the term
uh the true class is zero so we got the
correct prediction
um and it shows us you know um
it's going to relay to us the relative
future importance
and these are log odds and since it's a
binary classification task
the uh likelihood of something being
class
zero is the inverse of it being class
one so that's why you see these have the
same number
um just on different sides
um but so you know you can test this
with different uh
observations and what this is going to
do is give you an idea of what are the
relevance of your features
and also are these similar across
different observations
um which can tell you you know different
things about your district your
underlying distribution
and this is another this is another
phase where you could decide to keep
moving forward and
generate new information um and you know
think about it and turn into knowledge
or you could dive deeper at this point
and say hey uh
age is the most important feature for
this one but
for these observations it's actually the
month um how do we reconcile this
uh we do it again with a different class
or with a different observation
um and as you can see this one
had different feature uh values
so yearboard 3m was very important for
determining this so once again
it's an iterative process uh this is
something where we could keep re-running
this
keep going at it um i don't want to say
you need to know when to give up but you
should know when to move forward and
when you can
have new areas to uh you know kind of
dabble in um all right i know i don't
want to eat into the next speaker's
time so i'm gonna try and get through
this uh
this is this is chat values uh shop
values is based off game theory once
again these are all based off of
academic papers um and there's
documentation behind the implementations
but what we're doing is
um we're also you know doing feature
relevance it's just
uh the way it is uh computed is
different and then the way that we can
relay it
is different as well so things on that
are in red
are contributing to a higher percentage
prediction and things from
uh in blue are detracting from that
uh so you know the argument could be
made that uh
their features that detract from your
overall prediction could be removed
um we didn't do that once again because
that wasn't the scope of this it was to
get you thinking
um but yeah so we can see oh this is
kind of consistent with one of our
observations but perhaps we could test
this
on the whole data set or more
observations things of that nature
um and it's important this is all python
and it's pythonic in the sense these can
all be treated as
objects so you can actually take these
values and map them uh create a matrix
and you know
do some pretty cool plotting uh this is
just you know how you use the baseline
tool right out of the box
um we're gonna look at monotonicity and
faithfulness these are two metrics from
ibm monotonicity
is uh the idea are your features
monotonically additive
meaning if we have features f1 through
fn um
is f1 plus f2 uh lead to
increases in accuracy or not
um so it's a it's a boolean it's either
all of your features are contributing
more information to a correct prediction
or one feature is not contributing and
therefore it's not monotonic
um faithfulness is for things like lime
and shop where
there's perturbations so the
computations for your explanations
and your actual model aren't there's not
one-to-one parity
that being said uh faithfulness
determines the degree
of parity so you know you're shooting
for something probably above
0.6 um it is a float value from negative
one to one and that's going to indicate
to you like
if it's negative one that means your
future
explanations probably mean close to
nothing um
once i think the threshold is above like
point six that's where you'd be like
okay we are
starting to deduce actual information
from our data
um so this is how you compute it using
aix 360.
as you can see less than one percent of
our uh
test records were monotonic which means
we should probably clean up some
features um
that probably means we need to clean up
the features which we said at the
beginning
and we got a value of nan for
faithfulness um which indicates that
there was probably some kind of uh
floating point error
on our end because faithfulness you know
we probably had
something that wasn't faithful um or
exploded outside of the negative one to
one bounds
and that causes a name um and you know
once again this is an inflection point
where we stop and say hey we're not
getting good monotonicity and we're not
getting good faithfulness if these are
relevant and meaningful metrics we need
to change something about our process
or the behaviors we're demonstrating
through our code and then you do it
so this is a histogram just showing you
how not faithful are uh
how how not faithful our algorithms were
um and the last thing i want to show you
guys this one's a little bit
uh out there because neural networks but
this is contrastive explanation so what
we're trying to relay with this is
um the high level concept is pertinent
negatives and positives
um where pertinent negative uh will
identify
the minimal set of features um that need
to be altered for
something to be classified as the other
class as your negative class in this
case not getting a loan
um and personal positives are the
opposite um and what they look like when
we run them
is uh so this is just you know
normalizing rescaling so that way we can
return our values
we create some arbitrary small neural
network uh
just so you know this neural network
does not work at all really
um just because as a small
little neural network's problem i can
work on this data set very well because
it's tabular and as you can see there's
a lot of
data pre-processing probably wanna do
but that's not the point um
the better the neural network works the
better our results are gonna be but what
i'm trying to demonstrate is once again
how the tools
can be used with your current workflow
so if you make neural networks
maybe this is a script you've written
before or something similar to this
um where you know we we run this we
pick our arbitrary loss uh values things
of that nature
um we evaluate we get some kind of
prediction
um this immediately indicates to you
that you know there's a soft max at the
end of this
last layer soft max um so
this is not a soft max value so our
neural network didn't work that being
said
we're gonna pretend like it did um so
that way i can show you what contrast of
explanations look like
so this is how we compute our pertinent
positive
these arbitrary hyper parameters we use
to control the search space
um i recommend reading the documentation
on this one
uh but the last thing i want to leave
you with is you know so we
rescale it do some pre-processing the
code's not
too important because it's not github um
as you can see these predictions are not
great but what it's going to what it's
going to relay is for pertinent negative
uh their age was 27 so what would have
to change
for them to uh be classified as not
opening um the reason that these
categorical values are numeric is
because i
encoded the whole data set i could have
you know made
two different neural networks to handle
different data modalities and then
concatenate their outputs and then put
another linear layer
uh i didn't do that um just because
that's i think that's overkill for this
uh that being said something you could
do and these explanations would probably
be much more relevant
uh and much more powerful so if that's
something you want to do
uh that'd be awesome um and then we can
see our current negatives
so you know uh these are the things that
are most likely needed to be changed
for us to get a negative prediction uh
so
previous is have they been contacted
previously and that seems to be the one
with the highest
weight meaning if someone has not been
contacted previously
they are more likely to not open up a
term
uh which makes sense um if you read the
data description
uh so this is for pertinent positives
it's basically the exact same thing
except we put it into
pertinent positive mode um
and this is what we get uh
so this is instead of uh an actual
integer value this just tells you the
degree it needs to change
so their age wouldn't need to change
their education would
uh the previous day's contact would and
um your bore 3m
and number of employed and then once
again we can print it off
and euroboard 3m and uh p days
are the most uh pertinent uh features
so with that being said i
am done with my talk so i don't want to
eat into the other speaker's awesome
talk as well
so uh i'll stop sharing my screen
and if anyone has any questions uh
that'd be cool
but thanks so much tyler and anita
yeah that was definitely an awesome talk
austin i have a question for sure
that i want to ask uh based on some of
the work that you've done in the past
and some of the work you're interested
but other folks definitely feel free
uh to write any questions in the chat
we're happy to read those out for the
group as well as feel free to unmute
yourself and ask austin himself
but the question that i have which i'm
curious about is
uh do you go into based on your
experience into kind of creating a model
optimizing for a metric to based on
trying to solve a specific problem and
then find out only after that the
stakeholder that you gave it to or the
product owner you gave it to
is then looking for an explanation
behind that and then you have to go back
to the drawing board and then
look at more explainable models or do
you
find that from the get-go you're going
into it trying to
automatically figure out how to explain
a model
uh to whoever you're delivering it to
yeah so um like i said i've been with
ibm a year
uh a little bit more than a year now but
my
you kind of described both both modes of
thoughts i had so i i first started
writing and like
data scientists ibm like ooh i could do
all this cool stuff like i'm just gonna
every neural network like you know i
just approach every project like all the
neural networks
all the layers let's do this uh what i
quickly realized is one
the technical chops it takes to just
like implement neural networks for real
data that's not from kaggle it might be
not clean um doesn't work secondly
scaling it and all the devops and ai ops
behind that to get it to work
that's a lot of work um the third thing
is when you do go to stakeholder like
you said like
hey you wanted me to determine if you're
getting fraudulent checks so i created a
32-layer convolutional neural network
with like that
you see people's eyes glaze over and
they're kind of like they're like did
are we gonna get less fraudulent checks
or you know what i'm saying
um versus now i kind of go into it where
i'm very much about the problem problem
isolation the first meeting i'm saying
like hey
what are your major uh what are your key
performance indicators
what are the numbers that you're going
to be looking at move
to determine the success or failure and
then what i try to do
is align the way i perform my work with
those expectations that way rather than
me going full steam ahead being very
technical and kind of dragging them
uh we can move in alignment and that and
i can communicate with them in like
terms and be like hey
this uh this project that you're the
avenues we're taking for this project
don't
don't leak let don't look like they're
going to determine a successful outcome
that being said there are some under
employed tools we'd like to look at
and then i let them know the time
constraints what's it going to do
normally much happier i'm able to
perform a better job and they get a
better
solution at the end of it so i hope that
kind of answers your question
yeah for sure this is definitely uh i
feel like this is such a challenging
balance to try to solve for and it's
really
interesting to get your perspective from
that because personally i try to go into
like all right we're going to try to
solve this over this is the best
and then all of a sudden i have to
explain something and i'm looking back
and be like hmm
uh maybe i need to be thinking about
this slightly different especially in
you know if we're looking at loans or
you know in healthcare for instance i
think
a lot of these challenges come up but
yeah i definitely appreciate your your
thoughts on that and
i'll open the floor for any other folks
who have questions definitely feel free
to chime in
on the chat as well as feel free to
unmute yourself
and then one last point to piggyback off
what you said though um
i do think it's very important and it's
a little humbling it's something i
learned
a few months in uh explainability will
really help you relay beyond like code
reviews and meeting with people who are
smarter than you um
it's going to relay to you what you
don't know because you don't know what
you don't
know so like an example is like i did a
topic analysis right and i'm coming in
i'm like
i'm going to do negative matrix
non-negative matrix factorization and
lda
and this and that and then it's like i
i had an arbitrary state what's a deer
can you explain me what a dare cliff
distribution is
and i thought i knew what it was but you
know it goes back to that thing i said
at the beginning i couldn't explain that
to a five-year-old i couldn't explain
that to a very well-educated
person who wants me to do something for
them so then i realized like
i'm using a tool that i don't unders you
know so then i went back to the drawing
board and then
it and that helps you that helps you in
the future because then you create a
suite of algorithms that you're very
much uh and you know have good knowledge
of
i guess is what i'm trying to say
what other tutorials can we play with on
this top
uh so there's the mix um
aix 360
is what i would check out and then um
yeah so the bluemix ax 360 is what i
checked out the
papers and then um like the product
version of this from ibm is open scale
so i'd look at that my clapback for data
and the open sources aix 360.
um so i say a composition of those two
and then there
are some other good ones so uh there's
an r based package
from google which is called like mit
diff or mndiff
uh and then there's one from facebook
called captum which is really good for
like neural networks
and images so
those are just some places i'd start but
uh ais 360 is the most approachable for
my
point of view
all right any final questions we'll give
it a
five second pause just in case any folks
have any final questions before we pass
it over to anita
yeah thanks again tyler and anita for
having me and thanks for uh being a
great audience everyone
all right awesome thank you austin
definitely appreciate it i know i have a
lot to do after this because a lot of
code i want to review
definitely a lot of things that i took
notes on so big appreciation
to you and tim for joining us today and
with that
i'm going to pass over to anita
all right thank you tyler so our next
presentation
is by angela vujick and i'll let her
share her screen in the meantime i'll
just give a brief introduction
she's a phd researcher at the mit media
lab who works at the intersection of
computer science
neuroscience and design to develop
biosensing technology for mental and
emotional health
angela seeks to start a new area in her
field coined gut brain technology
or interfacing sorry about that and
she developed and is testing a gut brain
computer interfacing that could enable
individuals to
sense and modulate their gut state with
the goal of connecting it to
their mental well-being with that i'll
turn it over to angela
hey guys thank you so much for having me
thank you anita for inviting me
after hearing me talk at spectra um i
hope everyone is staying
safe and uh just out of curiosity do you
see the presenter view or the full
slides
i see this interview okay oh do you see
the presenter view
uh okay hold on guys
let me just restart i've had this
problem before
always difficult with the two desktops
okay
let me go on my main desktop and see if
that works
how about now
it's main slides okay so this is going
to be
very different from what you guys are
probably used to hearing
uh i will be talking about what i
consider a very oop excuse me
let me go back
i will be talking about what i consider
a very basic
introduction to brain computer
interfacing
and how you can get started at home
hacking and prototyping
with these kinds of devices if this is
something that interests you
because especially in these days more
and more consumer devices are becoming
available
and it's surprisingly accessible
to purchase one of these devices and
start recording your own brand signals
at home
so in today's presentation i will first
try and get you up to speed
with these technologies
then we're going to talk about the
hardware component how exactly i put
together
the headphones and how you need to
set up the electrodes all those fun
details
and then last i will be discussing the
software component
which is where the python code comes in
which unfortunately i will say
due to some uh deprecation in the open
vci libraries the code i wanted to run
doesn't work but i am totally happy to
walk through it
and show you guys how simple doing this
kind of stuff can be
alright so first getting up to speed
a little bit about myself i have been
doing work with
brain signals since 2015
five years now which is crazy to think
about and
i've done a number of projects uh
including
creating glasses that can detect brain
signals
but the focus of my master's thesis was
taking my experience
with recording brain signals and using
it to create a device
that actually sits on the surface of
your abdomen
to record stomach signals i'm not going
to be talking about this today
but if you are interested in something
like this i definitely encourage you to
look up my work
so i like to think that what i'm doing
is combining computer science
neuroscience and design
because i care about what science can
tell us about
how the brain works about how computer
science
can make new kinds of technology
possible and how design can make those
things accessible to anyone
and my goal is to tackle mental and
emotional health which we know
is one of the biggest issues of our time
and very ironically the very
technologies that are supposed to help
us are
starting to harm us and almost a black
mirror-esque way
which speaking of black mirror for those
who've seen it before
which i hope some people have seen
at least one episode of black mirror
because it may be a sign of what's to
come
what are mine reading headsets anyways
so any device that's meant to read brain
signals
is going to be recording some
kind of indication of neuronal activity
this can happen
through electricity through the
basically
electricity produced by neuron
activation
it can happen via blood flow measuring
the increase in blood flow to certain
parts of the brain
uh but in particular you can categorize
all these devices and you know whichever
part of the brain that they're recording
into invasive devices and
non-invasive devices hold on
i lost i lost view of my mouse for a
second
so in these two categories the invasive
devices are
similar to what you'll hear neuralink
working on they are anything that
requires
breaking the skin or even removing part
of the skull to insert electronics
in that area between the brain and the
skull
and then on the other hand a lot of the
new research that's been coming out
recently on
bcis is in the non-invasive area
this is what we're going to be talking
about today and in particular
we will focus on electro encephalography
aka eeg it's a complicated word
but don't be afraid of it because all it
means is
electro electricity and then encephalo
head electricity from the head so
the origins of the eeg go back to
i think it's almost 100 years now when
hansberger
was conducting these experiments putting
conductive pieces of metal on his head
and measuring the voltage difference on
his
head and literally all the scientists at
the time called him crazy
and didn't think what he was doing was
worth anything
but it turns out he could record
um activity of the so-called alpha
wave that became very famous later and
now when we see how much uh
work is going on in the area of these
non-invasive recordings
we can see how important what he was
doing was even though people called him
crazy
so when you put these conductive
basically we call them electrodes uh but
it can be any conductive material on the
head in these specified locations
what you get is that
the certain neurons in the brain folds
called the sulci
will be oriented so that their waves
of electricity their activity grouped
together typically it's i think it's a
few
it could be a few million neurons or a
few uh like a large-scale neurons that
the
eeg is recording their activity
is picked up as these
electric signals this is where the term
brain waves comes from and they're
either rhythmic or dysrhythmic activity
over certain parts of the brain
represents certain kinds of activity
and this very huge
set of signals is exactly what you would
expect to see
from that cap on the left
but the cool thing recently is that a
lot of new forms of wearable eeg are
coming out
even though if you google eeg you won't
see
any of these devices you'll see the cap
that i showed you on the previous slide
but these days uh i mean this has been
going on for over 10 or 20 years already
but we're really starting to see uh
materialize
the eeg electrodes being integrated
into everyday devices one of the most
famous examples
is the muse headband which is becoming
popular among meditators
and in particular
you can use the muse headband to
detect some form of engagement or
relaxation
while you're meditating and it's been
receiving some decent reviews so we're
not sure
if this is what's truly going to you
know break
brainwave devices into the market in my
lab
in the middle here is natalia who's
creating a pair of eeg
glasses so those glasses that she's
wearing can detect your brain signals
and your levels of engagement
and then lastly in the bottom right you
see an
example of so-called in-ear
eeg which to me is a very exciting area
kind of inspired what i'm talking about
today
uh and it's essentially from within the
ear canal you can pick up signals
almost even better than you can on the
head because
in a kind of faraday cage kind of way it
isolates the electrodes from noise in
the environment
and believe it or not you can also
record bring signals from there too so
you can easily
imagine that not just the headphones
that i'm wearing today but
that maybe 10 years from now or 20 years
from now we'll be purchasing
headbutts like our airpods could be able
to detect our brand signals who knows
maybe apple was already working on
something like that
and of course these uh in the past five
or ten years what i think is really
exciting too
is this explosion of hacking and
prototyping eeg
and this just involves taking the basic
hardware components
and detecting voltage differences across
the surface of the head and realizing
yeah that's eeg those are brain signals
and in the bottom right there we see a
little bit of the baby of the concept
conceptualization of open bci
which is one of the most famous and
popular let's say
open source uh hacking
bci kits that you could purchase and
typically it comes with just one board
and a usb dongle to connect it to your
computer you can also purchase
this or create at home actually you
don't have to purchase it if you have a
3d printer
uh this enormous headset that you
probably won't be wearing
in public but it's very fun to use in
your home
it has all the features that you need
for
any kind of basic brain computer
interfacing and then the really cool
thing about this
is because there's no signal filtering
in the hardware
you can apply this same technology to
other parts of the body you can measure
your heart rate
you can measure muscle activity i use
this to measure stomach activity
so it's really cool i mean of all the
things
uh of all your organs basically in your
body that can produce this kind of
activity
you can actually use open bci so
i'm not going to go into all the
technical details shown here about it
because you of course can look at the
website and look it up later
but it's really cool and actually a lot
of researchers use it too for
prototyping
and this is kind of the entry point like
if you know how to program
you could really pick one of these up
and get going uh
of course besides all the things you
need to learn about the brain
but in any case i was going to mention
that
the price is slightly prohibitive it's
pretty expensive
i think still for a normal person it
costs 500
but there are some cheaper alternatives
that are a little bit more difficult to
work with because
they don't have like the level of
software that comes with this
now we said a lot about vci but i wanted
to make sure that everybody understands
what this is brake feeder interfacing
aka bci is when you create
a interface that is somehow
tied into your brain signals either
you're controlling something directly
or some mental state you're having or
activity
is controlling something else or
influencing the environment
so an example of this that actually is
from a conference that i went to in
berlin
is
so what's being shown here is that i
won't go through the whole video
is that there's more sparkles and stars
as the users or person's
mental workload increases and of course
this may not be the ideal
application to use in your everyday but
it just shows like if you can measure
mental workload
then you can start to think about how
that can be implied in many different
ways
and then work that i did at georgia tech
which was my undergrad not sure if i
made that clear
was this interface for people who are
paralyzed
to communicate how they're feeling using
their brain signals
so the way that it works is uh
the individual focuses on the emoji that
represents
how they're feeling and then there's
something called
a p300 evoked uh
event related potential that occurs
when the blinking square
is on that emoji it's interesting i
won't get into the details about it but
it's cool
because basically if you're focusing on
something there's a spike
in brain activity that you can pick up
and then you can use that to control an
interface
so the basic structure i think i should
be good on time but i'll
try and go fast so the basic structure
of any bci
is this loop you're going to have some
signal acquisition
you'll be doing pre-processing on the
signal feature extraction
classification and then afterwards you
can send it over
to the application whatever you want to
do with your data
but as you can see here the two basic
components are hardware component
and a software component so that's how
i'm going to explain what i'm doing
today
so to start with a hardware component uh
the i i don't want to you know
talk through this slide too much this is
more so
like when you guys get the slides after
this you can use this as a reference
but basically what you'll need to put
together the headphones are
one of the eeg headsets electrodes of
course
a little extension cord that will become
important later
batteries conductive gel wow this is
starting to look really complicated
i promise it's not that bad when you
have this slide
as a reference later and
before we dive in further to all of the
fun parts of putting that together i
want to talk quickly about
how the electrodes need to be placed
there's something called the
international 1020 system
or the 1020 system for short that
is the standard way that people who
research
eeg record signals and also if you see
one of those caps
this is how if you've wondered how the
electrodes are placed on those caps this
is how it's done
and it's a standardized system that uses
10
increments and 20 increments to
determine
kind of where each brain lobe is
so if you see the letter f that means
the frontal lobe the letter c
is referring to central p is referring
to parietal and o
to occipital which occipitals the vision
uh
flow so in
all of this you can go even further
and go not just have this many
electrodes but if you keep on applying
the system
go down to my god you can have 64 128
electrodes you can really do a lot
but typically people use 32 and then for
prototyping purposes the board that we
have
only has eight so you can kind of pick
and choose
in this system where you would want to
place the electrodes and then here i've
kind of marked
based on the placement of my headphones
where they're recording on my head and
it's somewhere between central and
parietal
which is pretty interesting because
that's important
for certain kinds of things like
emotions
and in some cases like motor activity
and then it's not really shown very well
here
but when you put these electrodes on
your head you also need to have
two other electrodes to make a valid
signal
you need to have a reference electrode
and a ground electrode
and usually the ground is put on the
earlobe it's kind of hard to see
obviously because of the headphones but
i am wearing it right now
and the reference is placed behind the
ear on the mastoid bone so like if you
were to put your finger
behind your ear and kind of feel uh
this kind of raised bump that's
typically where reference is placed for
these electrodes and that's actually
what
allows the bio amplifier to pick up a
voltage difference
on your head so creating the headphones
i created
a really simple setup that used
the bio amplifier which is that board
you see on the left
on one side and the battery pack
uh which is on the right side i don't
know if this is easy to see
because i lost myself you want soon
um i'll figure out how to fix it later
because
you know not crucial but what you'll see
is that you have
the board on one side the battery pack
on the other
and then those two extra gold things
hanging those are the other electrodes
for ground and reference that i just
talked about that i'm wearing on the
earlobe and the ear
or a mastoid bone and then in addition
you'll see
in the headband itself those three
electrodes
uh that i was kind of showing you the
location of them earlier
and then in addition you see that
cord that has a box on it that's a
button
for the battery to just turn the open
bci on and off
typically the open bci has a switch
on the side that turns it on and off but
i personally have found that that's
really difficult to use and
sometimes will accidentally turn off and
there's a number of issues with it so
having this little button
is kind of a godsend i really recommend
it
all right
so the basic process that i took while
putting this together was first of
course to plug in all the electrodes
then i used hair ties believe it or not
it's that simple i use hair ties to
attach
the open bci and the battery pack
to the sides and then afterwards you see
me take some measuring tape
what i'm doing is i'm looking at the
length of the headphones to make sure
that i get it exactly center
and i'm also marking it with tape where
i want to put the electrodes based on
the 1020 system
i also mark the reference electrode to
make sure i don't confuse it with the
other electrodes
and then afterwards because these wires
are really long
and kind of annoying to deal with i wrap
them
just you know just in a little coil to
make things easier
so that they're not hanging all over the
place otherwise it'd be kind of a
nightmare
and then using those pre-marked
locations
uh i went back and
put in the electrodes on the headband
and let's see here
there we go i actually just realized i
made a mistake i
put the electrodes on backwards but then
i fixed it and that's basically
the entire process of course it's a
fast motion video but
it didn't take that long and i thought
it was like remarkably simple it didn't
require any fancy materials
so the final result looks something like
this
and i wore it for a while it's not
too terribly heavy if you do have
battery alternatives that would make the
biggest difference like when putting
this together if you have
anything that can replace the battery
pack
other than a 3.7 lipo battery because
that actually
will give you problems with the open vci
but i won't get into that right now um
otherwise that's the heaviest part of
this headset and why i think
it makes it besides the obvious
prototyping
appearance that makes it very hacky and
as you can see the little
uh battery button is hanging in the back
all right so this is the probably
most relevant to what you guys typically
talk about
at these meetings but still very far
away from it
so now that we have our headphones let's
dive into the software component
in any bci which i talked about earlier
uh with the basic structure but
something that i
in particular really enjoy referring to
is the bci cycle
that breaks down the basic processes
that any bci uses
um they they say stimulation here but i
would actually
prefer to say feedback mesoposis
simulation
and it comes from a paper that i believe
is freely accessible
and if not i can send it to you
so once we have this basic process
down of analyzing the signals you really
wonder like okay what are we looking for
uh besides these event related
potentials and evoke potentials which i
will not talk about today because i
think
it's a little bit more complex a lot of
what people look at
are power increases in these
eeg frequency bands now
if you look at the descriptions you'll
see that
each of them has some kind of based on
many many decades of research has these
associations with certain kinds of
mental states or things that we would
commonly understand
and so when you're looking at eeg
signals and you hear people say the
alpha signal you hear people say
the theta signal this is what they're
referring to
and the frequency bands are not listed
on this uh graph of course
but they are in order from fastest to
slowest
so the basic process when you're
approaching the
raw eeg signal is that first you would
do the pre-processing
and filtering that we're talking about
before and then afterwards
do your feature extraction and
prediction and provide feedback
but to make this super simple like if
you were
really you know if you were
really a beginner and you were going to
take
each bullet and write a few lines of
code to do it or even write just one
line of code
this is what it would look like you
would take your raw signal
probably in some n dimensional numpy
array you would filter for the frequency
band of interest which for eeg
is usually 5 to 50 hertz you would
remove power line noise which
in the united states is 60 hertz in
europe it's 50 hertz and i'll show you
this in just a second
then you'd add any other kind of
denoising or filtering that you want but
these are the basic steps
and of course afterwards that's when you
can do the fun stuff
like feature extraction and prediction
thing you know for mental states
uh like workload like i was talking
about before
and when you're doing this you can
either analyze your data
offline i like to do this in jupiter
notebooks typically
or you can analyze uh your data
in real time with an application that
basically takes like a few seconds of
like a window of data
and is constantly doing this process
and uh using that to create some kind of
feedback loop like in those examples i
was showing you before
so if you're curious like oh what's the
future like
what exactly are we looking for a great
example of this would be
the engagement index which is this
super simple ratio of the beta alpha
and theta frequency bands but over a
number of studies
has been shown to be correlated with
someone's active attention
to some kind of
i mean it can be multiple things you
know it can be reading it can be
watching a movie
um but you know the kind of colloquially
understood definition of engagement
it's kind of correlated with this uh
ratio and of course this does have
i have to mention this does have uh
ethical implications
uh in terms of like when these
technologies start to become
more common how can this be used you
know kind of
manipulated by the companies that are
selling these devices
uh but i can talk more about that at the
end for
now this is a great example of what a
feature could look like and if you were
to create
your own eeg app you could use this
and something else that is very
important to mention
are that artifacts are really common in
eeg signal
and they are the biggest problem
with doing this kind of research i
show here an example of just eye
movement and like typically
i mean you wouldn't think like if you
were recording from
the surface of the head that you could
pick up on just
eye movement uh what your eyes are going
back and forth but that is
louder it has a stronger power than the
brain signals and so this happens quite
frequently
this and movement artifacts blink
artifacts muscle artifacts
all kinds of artifacts coming to your
signal but i would say
if you want to prototype and have fun
and get into it
this is something like the artifact
removal from your signal
you can you can try it but i would say
like the better way to go is to just
pretend and create perfect conditions
for your signals starting out
and then later on you can worry about
like creating cool algorithms to remove
artifacts
so with that being said uh how do you
interface with openvci and
using python the old standard was
openbci python it is technically
deprecated but very usable
i actually find it to be much simpler
than the new standard though you know
it's also just because i was using it
for so
long i was probably very accustomed
to the format and api and everything
and then when they made the switch i i
obviously prefer the old one because i
was using it for longer but
i have to say the new standard is brain
flow
and i can show you on my screen share
what that looks like
and of course if you want to learn more
about all of this
you can read the documentation online
what i really love about the opci is
that they have
not only great documentation they also
have an active forum wow i really sound
like an advertisement i promise this is
not an advertisement this is not
sponsored in any way
i think it's just objectively like the
easiest way to get into this
with software experience so in any case
they have a very active forum and also
very good very detailed documentation
and then my personal favorite for using
python
to analyze eeg or any biosignals
in general is biospy this does not
give you uh necessarily you know like
super advanced uh
you know mechanisms of recording your
signal but it is a
really really flexible and easy to use
toolbox that for example for the eeg
signal you can just
pass in your array and then you get the
filtered signal
you get each frequency band and a few
other like interesting bits of
information so for me it's just like
super simple cool easy to use
and a great way to get started like a
good add-on to
you know the other things i'll show you
and in general
i would say python is great for bci
there's a lot of researchers that use it
and even though it's not necessarily the
standard
in the bci field because a lot of people
in the bci field come from engineering
and i actually think like oftentimes
we'll be using matlab
or other forms or other programming
languages
um but python is becoming more popular
and i know that
just in general its level of usability
is very high flexibility
so i very much recommend it and here
i have a little place marker to exit the
presentation real quick
to share with you a few of the things i
talked about and a little bit of a code
walkthrough
so let's see here
just have to share the screen more time
i have it on multiple desktops so i'm
really hoping
that this is not oh i just saw a comment
that's great i'll get back to them at
the end but let me finish consuming the
walkthrough
all right wait hold on i'm gonna share
the whole desktop as opposed to
the applications
all right do you guys see the open bci
gui
you see it awesome so this is like if
you don't want to do any code and also
because this is a really easy way to
demonstrate
the signals that i can record right now
um once you get your open bci going
and you have the electrodes on your head
so right now
my electrodes are actually uh here
and here and this is actually a
technical difficulty i was having
is that two of them are not getting
enough power so only one of them is
working but that's okay
then also the ground and reference
around the ear
let's see
all right so just to demonstrate what i
was talking about before
let's see increase the scale that
so this is not it's not a very high
quality signal right now
i'm not sure what happened because i
really kept everything the same
from the first time that i tested this
but that's okay i can kind of show you
guys
what the basic interface looks like and
how to approach and how to use it
so here this is where you can pick the
frequency band that you would like to
focus on
and like i mentioned before the bp
filter ak band pass filter
is typically from 5 to 50 hertz for all
the eeg signals that you would be
interested in
then the notch filter is for power line
noise
which is detected by
the device surprisingly in the us it's
60 hertz and in europe it's 50. so
that's why there's this other
um option here but of course keep it at
the
power line noise that is appropriate for
your country
and besides that uh the
plot here on the right is the fft
or the fast fourier transform and
usually you should be able to see like
some really
interesting stuff over here um but i
i don't think that my signal quality
is going to be high enough to do some
demonstrations but you can see that like
if i do
tap the top of my head that there's a
lot of noise in the signal
and that it is actively recording from
my head
and um like in general
like if you wanted to use this to get
started with doing eeg at home
it's a fun way to do it
all right and one thing to mention is
that when you do these recordings they
will be saved to
uh text files or csvs on your computer
in the location of your choice and
they will not be this is very important
to mention because a lot of people don't
realize this
the signals are not saved with the
filters
so when you do recording from here and
you go to pick it up it does not have
powerline noise removed it does not have
a bandpass filter
that's when you go in and apply your own
pre-processing and feature extraction so
very very important to mention
all right the next thing is how
i would typically structure my
open bci code this is the deprecated
version
that needs to be updated to brain flow
but um i can walk you through real quick
like what it looks like and
um i don't have everything neatly in a
github
repo for people to access but i'm happy
to make that happen if people are
interested
so usually you would have to manually
import the serial port that the openvci
is on
but i learned that the formatting is
always going to be
usp serial uh dash capital d
so i wrote a quick little thing that
just
finds that in the open ports
and then automatically selects it as
your open bci port
this will only work on mac os it does
not work on linux and
microsoft are excuse me windows
because they have a different formatting
for their
um ports so
you will have to figure that out on your
own device but i know that
windows uses calm and
besides this there's some really really
simple stuff here
um i have this code with an optional
um extension to make an osc bridge that
can send the
samples of data and any feature you want
to another application and i've used it
before in my research
but will not really be talking about it
today
and besides that oh can everyone see
everything
i feel like i really should have asked
this before jumping in
so we can see our sublime um
our code on sublime okay awesome that no
that's that's what i want
so after that there's a few
um things to keep in mind
also when you're getting data from the
open bci
the ti 80s1299
by amplifier that it uses and also
the data that it saves is not in
microvolts so for example if you're like
reading a paper
and you see oh this feature like this
data should have this
n micro volts that's not going to be the
value
stored in the openvci sheet i mean if
you use
python to stream the openpc or you use
the gui you need to convert it
to microvolts if you want i mean
obviously you don't need to but you
should
because that's how all of the uh
eeg data is talked about and analyzed um
and you don't you don't need to copy it
from my code this is very nicely in the
open bci docs but i have it laid out
how exactly um to use the voltage
reference and gain to calculate the
microvolts
so let's see here hmm how to explain the
code
okay so it's actually quite simple and
of course you guys are probably python
experts and get that too
um but basically what this code does
is it opens up an open bci board object
and then it tries to
start streaming from the board using
that open serial port connecting to it
and then if there's
this is just something that i did for
myself if there's a keyboard interrupt
it stops streaming
and then besides that it's going to stop
streaming once your experiment time you
can set
however many seconds you want to do it
is over
and afterwards i have some just some
print statements for the terminal to
show you what's going on
and then starting from the top
when you have your raw eeg signal
what i did here was use uh the biospy
as you can see here biased by output
i use the biosphy eeg module
with the data the sampling rate which i
didn't talk about before
openbci is 250. and with
the uh array of electrodes
um and it says show falls because
typically it would try to open up a map
plot
plot and from this i grab
the filtered signal and what it's doing
if you look at the like biosphere
library
is doing a really simple um taking out
that
or doing a bandpass filter and then
after that
i have a separate function after apply
preprocessing
get feature which here i showed
the engagement index that i was talking
about
in my slides and all you need to do
if you have the bias by toolbox is
grab the eeg object i know it's a little
bit redundant but this was easy for me
and then just grab the theta alpha which
is split into high and low alpha so i
combined it
and beta frequency bands and
because all of these are being stored
as numpy arrays you can very easily just
do the ratio in one line and then
afterwards return
the mean of that so that while this is
running because this is meant to be used
in real time you can get the engagement
levels
second by second or every two seconds
you can set the
you know length of time that you would
like to use
but typically it's anywhere between two
seconds to 15 seconds
and then after that there's a little bit
of stuff that's actually for the
osc bridge so not very important it's
just
uh putting together the
packet and there's a
little bit more data that does this
um like basically if you like wanted to
take your engagement index
and send it to another application to do
whatever you want to do with it
you can do that here and that's the
basic process
once you get that data you can export it
and save it and so yeah i share all this
to
basically uh show how
uh doing this kind of you know getting
started with this
is pretty straightforward or at least to
me
of course ask questions because i'm not
checking the chat but in a few minutes
i'll finish up
and we'll talk um
and in general with this level
of sophistication you won't be able to
do things like record signals while
somebody is
walking because there's too many motion
artifacts and there's a few other
restrictions
but it's good for recording signals
while sitting still
in a chair there was a quick question in
the chat about whether you can use eye
movement signal to figure out
what the user is looking at is that
possible great question
so i think that the uh
that's like a perennial question
of eog but i think it is
possible using the uh
basically like if you have a
asymmetrical
power increase in like like if you have
electrodes on the head
because the electrode from here is not
going to pick up eye movement it's
actually like if you were recording from
your forehead
you're going to be seeing that and
if you have asymmetrical power
differences
in your left electrodes and right
electrodes
you could theoretically uh
look at like if there's an increase in
power
on one side that it's likely that the
person
is um looking towards that side or not
looking towards it you know like you
have to figure out exactly what it means
um but i think if you want to do eog
with the open bci
you could configure your electrodes
to be like around the eyes and to get
really high quality eog so if that was
something you were interested
in doing yeah you don't even have to
record you know like eeg signals you can
put the electrodes on your face wherever
you'd like
and then for sure you can get some uh
signal that can determine where someone
is looking
but the level of specificity is not
high like it's not like eye tracking
i've used eye tracking before and
this is much more like you're going to
see
left or you're going to see right you
might be able to see
up and down up and down is very hard
very very very hard to pick up through
the signal
but you can get left and right
all right cool so let's see if there's
anything else i want to share
i have this like uh jupiter notebook but
honestly
i think i think that it's um
has like similarities with what i was
showing before just a little bit more
detail so i'm gonna move on because
we're running out of time
i feel like i've been talking for way
too long so i'm excited to have like
a back and forth discussion okay
so an example of what the data may look
like with the engagement index
uh it could be something like this which
you know
to be honest like to the untrained eye
it looks like
a bunch of spikes and also to me it
looks like a bunch of spikes it
spikes it's actually not so informative
but you do start to see
some kind of upward trend so we want to
look at this more closely
so something that we can do is
apply two second windows with a one
second overlap
and take the mean of the signal in those
windows
and immediately makes the data a little
bit more clear
but we can go even further than that
and uh we can do a
i applied here a smooth triangle
function
uh i believe it was to the fifth degree
to be able to see the data more clearly
and then
immediately uh when it comes to
let's say like the example i was trying
to show you is the engagement index
we can see this slow and steady increase
in the ratio between beta
and alpha and theta which is
exactly you know based on prior
literature
what we would want to see so this is an
example
of a study where um
people were studying and they wanted to
see
like can they use some positive
messaging
to improve engagement while people
are trying to learn and they saw some
increase associated with their positive
messaging
so when we start to do just like a few
simple steps
with these signals we can see the
for example like for me these are my eeg
signals
like a increase in engagement while i
was doing tasks
it's pretty cool so
i think i am perfect on time because i'm
approaching my conclusion
uh how can this be used like for
you in your daily environment i mean
obviously i think these kinds
of technologies are at a point where
they're kind of for
fun you know there's a lot of serious
engineering that needs to be done before
they can be full-fledged consumer
products
but of course if this sounds like
something interesting
you can put together your own eeg
headphones or just record your own
signals
and see your engagement index while
doing a task and then there's something
similar
to what my colleague in my lab was doing
natalia
which is providing vibrational
sorry haptic or vibrational feedback
when you start to lose focus
and interestingly enough it can
help with engagement though that doesn't
necessarily mean it's the best way to
implement it you can use the data
however you'd like you can also
do everything offline and just take your
data over the course of a few hours
and then take let's say your calendar
or just have like a little uh journal or
even
uh tape you know what you were doing
during the day
and start to see like under what
conditions do you
find yourself being more or less engaged
and
of course this is something that maybe
we
as like in the kind of work that we're
doing we have
meetings we have checking emails we have
programming like a lot of different
kinds of tasks going on
this could be great for students or if
you have kids like a
good way to like get them introduced
into this technology
and play around and use it while
studying
a more creative example would be like
the work of uh grace leslie who's
currently a professor at georgia tech
but was also at the media lab
who integrates these signals into her
flute performances and it's super cool
and kind of like people describe it as
uh i don't know different experience
like just knowing that you're
hearing the her brain signals as she's
performing adds
this kind of uh a different level of
intimacy to performance
that i think was already pretty intimate
and then even for myself
this is pre-pandemic just to be
completely clear
even for myself where i uh dj parties
at the media lab i'm always
interested in like how can i take these
headphones which are the same ones i'm
wearing in the picture and also in my
head right now
and integrate my brain signals into my
performance either
to multitask to control the lights in
the room
as as well as controlling the music or
to add like
a different level kind of like what
grace is doing like integrating your
emotions in the performance so there's a
bunch of creative
like both pragmatic and creative
applications
of this kind of uh work in this kind of
signal
all right so with that i thank you very
much
uh again my name is angela vuich i'm a
phd researcher at the media lab
you can reach me at a week at mit.edu
and also you can find me on twitter and
instagram which is currently
not the most active but i promise that i
do log in
thank you angela you know there's been
some discussions in the chat so i wanted
to get to them
first can you use the output from bci to
do some other activities using an
arduino
maybe do you know of any examples people
have done with
with the output let me go ahead and stop
sharing
unless there's something in the
presentation is interesting
all right
can you use the output from openbci to
do activities using an arduino
definitely and i've been on research
projects that do this exact thing for
example
you could use the
arduino to do ssvp which i didn't get to
talk about today but it's called steady
state
visually evoked potentials and it's when
you can
control something by focusing on
a light that is blinking at a specific
frequency
and um that's just like one example i
mean
the possibilities are absolutely endless
like if you wanted to
tie your brain signals to
i don't know some kind of ambient light
or you wanted to even
i don't know like anything anything that
is
uh connected can be
output and influenced or by
the data that you're recording the only
thing that i wouldn't expect
is to have like perfect levels of
control you know like
uh perfect levels of let's say like the
way that you can reliably
open your phone with almost 100 accuracy
uh with a bci like having a 90
rate of success is good which if you
think about it if like
one time out of 10 you couldn't open
your phone when you tried to open your
phone that's actually pretty frustrating
so that's something i would keep in mind
is that uh there are still
like a lot of things with this level of
eeg
um issues that you can expect
oh there's an article about eog on the
open bci website that is
awesome that is really really awesome
is it possible to use the brain signal
just before a migraine attack
i think it is i do have a colleague
who was recording their eeg signals
because they struggle with migraines and
they were
trying to figure out exactly like
what the signal looks like before during
and after
i don't think that they had success
but the biggest problem is that you need
to record
a ton of data like try and get your eeg
set up to be comfortable enough to be
able to record it
at all times and then also have really
good artifact removal
which is something that i mentioned i
didn't have time to talk about today
and i think with that you could start
collecting some
interesting data though i can't make any
promises
about whether or not you will
definitively have your like
here's the eeg with a migraine here's
the eg without a migraine because i know
someone who's worked on this and had a
lot of struggles
speculative question it's impressive to
see the origins of eeg
and how you're able to build tech into
the headset as a diy
where do you see this tech going in the
future are we going to be chipped at
birth and then figuring out how to
optimize a human is this too much
yes this is a really important question
i didn't get to talk today
about the ethical principles that guide
me when i'm doing my work but i do want
to publish something
about it because this is really
important like if you're creating these
kinds of things
for yourself it's fine but like
if if it's going to be used with anyone
else
there needs to be a level of consent
and also a level of information like
for example you shouldn't lie to someone
that you can detect a brain signal that
is impossible to detect
um just to sell a product and then
you know beyond that um
it's yeah like all i think that
especially
right now we are in an era of techno
pessimism because of surveillance
capitalism
and the attention economy and i actually
think that
my hope is that these kinds of
technologies should not be released
by companies who have an active interest
in knowing your attention
that this needs to be completely
separate and regulated
and uh all of your data needs to be
protected the same way
that your medical data is protected
right now
and beyond that because you ask me where
i see it going in the future
i'm not pessimistic about it
not being able to come into society and
benefit us
i definitely think this kind of
technology
is going to be able to change the lives
of people
especially who are paralyzed and change
the lives of people
who have certain kinds of mental
disorders
i'm not sure based on our understanding
right now
how it can revolutionize like you know
the lives of neurotypical people or
people who have full
motor function and are um typically able
but for people with disabilities i think
this is going to be really huge
and um really important if anyone here
has seen elon musk's neurolink
presentation
the claims he made were definitely
overstated like he was saying like oh
this technology is gonna cure
um alzheimer's uh this technology is
gonna cure parkinson's and it's like
well
we already showed that the parkinson's
you know is connected to
like parkinson's and alzheimer's have
connections to like the immune system
even though they're like studied as a
brain disorder so it's not really like
this kind of technology isn't really
gonna solve everything
i for sure um but it can be
really crazy amazing um
for people like i said that have certain
kinds of disabilities and mental
disorders
and are we going to be chipped at birth
and figuring out how to optimize a human
hmm yeah this is also really
interesting question for me because i
feel like right now in our society we
have a level
of inequality that makes it
like not the right environment to start
introducing these kinds of technologies
that
can really optimize you especially
if they're expensive and prohibited to
normal everyday people because they will
further exasperate our inequalities
i can't say for sure if this is too much
because the capabilities of the
technologies are so limited
that even if elon musk claims you can do
everything with his implanted device
it's not yet too much because we don't
understand enough about the brain
to truly know what we're doing and to
truly control people
that's just fact i have a small
driverless toy car
do you think trying to control a toy car
with the buci signals this is a huge
complicated project
i don't think so it depends on the level
of control you want to have
i could already think that you could
start doing
like a uh some arrows on the screen
that you could use to basically like if
you focus on one of them it can move
around the car
there's actually a lot of creative ways
that you could start to think about like
how to control your car um
i don't know what you mean by huge
complicated
project if you want to have like
two dimensions of control that could
probably be a fun
side project if you want to start
getting up into
four dimensions of could like if you
want to start getting up to like
really high levels of control it's going
to be complicated for sure
yeah what i meant was that um the
driverless car was actually programmed
in python so right now i'm programming
it in python
um so like i was thinking that using the
bci
i could um when you like when the driver
thinks that oh i want the car to go
right they don't have to like move the
steering like it'll automatically turn
right the car will climb
so this sounds like a great project for
fun
i i wouldn't from like a practical
standpoint
i wouldn't use the bci to control it but
only for fun
like if you want to feel like you're
controlling it with your mind
that's definitely a really fun project
i personally would recommend for this
using
motor imagery this is when you
imagine lifting your left arm or lifting
your right arm and you will see a power
increase
over the motor cortex with those
movements so for your application that
you just mentioned
you could do left or right by imagining
moving your
arm left or right it does require
training which i did not talk about
today but it's just like
any algorithm you need to collect a
certain number of samples before
it's good enough to learn um
how to do this but if you guys which
from understand you guys are well versed
in machine learning
then doing this kind of like just the
hard part for you will
just be getting the eeg up and running
and collecting data afterwards
the uh you know doing the machine
learning everything is your
jam like you can just make it happen so
i'd be excited for you to do that
let's see thank you yeah of course of
course
reposting adam's question earlier all
right i haven't seen the open bci boards
before
so i'm not sure if i could easily build
my own eeg but i did see the emotive
and have been wondering what i can do
with them are there downsides with
something like the emotive
and is there api missing pieces that i
might want for some smarter projects
interesting so i've tried the amount of
before i've had a lot of colleagues that
tried the emotive before
it's i don't know i haven't used the
most recent
version so i don't know if they provide
you with the raw data
but i would check to see do they provide
the raw data
but i will say that i did a bunch of
research
since i asked the question but uh they
do but it's 50 a month
i i guess that's uh i'm not sure rather
raw data would be
useful but raw data i think what
if you just want to do eeg
and you want to do some like really
simple stuff it can work the really
really nice thing
about the emotiv that you currently is
like
not as easy with open bci is just like
you just throw on the emotive and that's
it
it takes like five seconds to put it on
and that's a really big benefit like if
it takes like
a minute to set up your headset you
might be less motivated
to record signal right uh which sounds
kind of funny but
trust me like it does get
annoying the longer it takes to set up
so the really big benefit of using that
is um it's gonna be super easy to get
started they do a lot of the work for
you
um if you're a good programmer i don't
see anything wrong with like
i don't know like looking into
what they offer and how you can
customize it
in general i've always had more
fun and i've made more
headway using the open bci because it's
so customizable
but i also have a lot of knowledge about
all the different kinds of signals you
know
how to do ecg how to do stomach signals
how to do brain signals so i guess it's
like
if you don't have time for all of that
you can just throw on the emotive and
then you know you're recording brain
signals
so it's totally up to you
it's kind of like this like higher
customization
means more time lower customization
means less time but potentially less fun
so i hope that answers your question
oh thank you tim uh this
is super interesting yeah you're welcome
i
have a lot of fun doing this i don't
really get to talk to people
outside of my immediate realm of
research it's usually
you know only presenting to other people
that do eeg so i always have a lot of
fun
talking about this stuff and especially
now that companies like
neurolink are becoming mainstream and
black mirror is also popularizing the
dangerous effects of this kind of
technology i
also kind of want to show what's really
happening
when you're doing this kind of recording
and what the limitations are and to be
honest but to also be cautious
and be very clear that if you get into
this
you know you should be doing it for
yourself you should do it
if it's for someone else you need to
have their explicit consent
and also um you know
keep their data private or give them
full control over how the data is used
one question from the audience earlier
um was how does audio feedback to the
user influence the eeg
oh in this setup
i think in general in general
ooh this is such a broad question
that's really going to depend i can
imagine that there's some
uh there are some increases this is a
bit of literature i haven't looked at in
a while
um but i'd imagine that there's power
increases in the
like temporal lobe and like audio
processing centers
of the brain and besides that
audio feedback can just be like a cool
useful method to create a bci but
you know generally speaking you know i
can't really tell you like oh yeah if
you listen to a song
your brain signals are going to
synchronize with it
possibly um but i haven't looked at that
research in a while
so i think i saw another question what
is the biggest bottleneck right now
is it the hardware sensor or effective
signal processing
hmm
[Music]
that's a great question i personally
think
it's the sensor itself that the
way that we're recording signal right
now with these conductive materials
and also just using
electricity as our modality in general
is a huge limitation there needs to be
more innovation on the material science
side which is already happening
to make these signals easier to
record and also to reduce the signal to
noise ratio but most importantly
to figure out a recording method with
less artifacts
especially motion artifacts and
artifacts from
blinking like this is such a big problem
and
recording methods like what fmri uses
uh which is basically looking at change
in blood volume
get around this uh but the problem is
that they're extremely bulky and they're
not
portable so when we get to a point where
we can have
a portable fmri then i think we've
really revolutionized
like what we can do but right now the
form of that
is uh like i think the smallest form is
probably the size of a backpack
and the spatial resolution
is very shallow you know it's only like
a centimeter on the top of the brain
so you know like if we can get to a
point where we can have
the like recording mechanism uh with
less artifacts i think that's going to
be super important which like i think
maybe a lot of people would say oh
you need to have like the exact like
neuron you need to have
i don't know like a higher sampling rate
that goes beyond what we can do right
now but i actually
think the most important thing is to
reduce artifacts and if you
start having fun and getting into this
kind
of work you'll see that immediately
great thank you angela for this talk i
know you know it's past nine now and
we want to wrap up our meeting so thank
you so much to
both our presenters today and um
there will be some follow-up items that
we'll post on slack as well as on meetup
so that you can follow up and thank you
for joining us all tonight
thank you for having me